ok yeah it's ok it's your boy psych eval
hey I'm gonna look quest called taken
independence okay we gotta raise egg the
castle I gotta talk to press in here and
but I you know most important is Donald
Trump right here my main man strong so
that's there that's okay okay mm-hmm and
that's a nice little tells all right a
lot of wood for cribbage a lot of good
handle let's go that's good okay oh yes
I need to find Preston [ __ ] say there
is you think we're ready to rethink ago
yeah he's very dark yeah that's Tess
let's do this we'll do some recon and
meet you outside the cabin okay baby
let's tear this [ __ ] let's do this
[ __ ] words and [ __ ] for our that's
where it is oh good good good I would
get like a thousand miles away that's
okay it's okay mmm yeah a chloride there
and then calling you up a little before
Hank helps you know I'm saying psycho
likes his claws you know you know once a
what's a month the old pastor house
behind fixes my nails up okay let's do
this I always quick saved because no
matter how did it characters you could
be walking and also there's a [ __ ]
landmine up your [ __ ] blowing [ __ ]
out of your mouth she ain't supposed to
be in your mouth that's for sure like I
learned that I was [ __ ] let me just get
this lady yeah obey me yeah yeah yeah
okay right around here as paulownia
landlines let say a line right now you
just want good landline k
hey [ __ ] a [ __ ] mud lurk hey these
[ __ ] yeah thank Jesus what the [ __ ]
is that a while ok uh hello ma'am oh
Jesus what's that the makeup you put
makeup on a peg but it's all peg you
know it's tell peg okay okay okay okay
getting close and write a class OSS
where are we going psycho to solve our
kids Rose they're almost there okay I
get up to blow that man with half the
bits Jesus timing us computer I almost
blew and I haven't how can I guys I'm
I'm waiting this operation so I'm gonna
need this I'm gonna take this that's
this and i actually just give me all
your stuff you know how's everyone's
here general there it is pretty
impressive on a shuttle real name is
bored independence but the mini men
always just now you can see why ha ha
not really once we clear it out get that
radio tower up and running repair the
wall our primary objective vista to the
wall on this side is the most exposed
but if we circle around south shore are
we waiting for let's just give it now if
we split
we can flank him why not let them come
to us how do I get to choose well
general what do you think hey guy guns
blazing let's not overcomplicate if you
say so all right people you heard the
general let's move out try not to draw
their attention until we're in position
yeah Peleus hey show yes ik does this
you just say
let's say what do we have here
God God God God God hey guys little
leggies you know it out like that no
Jesus
this is what I live for you know
that logan area right here oh [ __ ] i got
no grenades does that it chateau ste ste
yeah looks like they've been yet we're
gonna have to take out these days
they'll be back before we know works
like a whole other side walls really
don't get any yeah a chance to step on
them chase ass
that's strong strong are you down here I
guess so now I get to use a sniper rifle
for stuff like this uh yeah Hannah an
ass [ __ ] that Jesus that yes that's that
yeah got [ __ ] this more stuff there I
think they trigger to Hatcher we get
near them [ __ ]
I'll guess [ __ ] face gosh I your face
[ __ ]
oh [ __ ] they're so small I got cute and
I'll take one are you guys don't want
one okay where's the last one everyone
like down there somewhere kill the mire
lurk Wayne where is that I'm really sure
where that is what yeah sure not that
she is [ __ ] a
ooh I got it uh head and I like that get
all Jillian shut I ever been aid I think
I should have a grenade fat man and
recreation oh yeah q stay here oh [ __ ]
no no no no ok ok i got these mines
whatever all i can AIDS ok class wreckin
a type cure this to hear pulse can a lot
with this in here ok now
[ __ ]
hey I just go down here and now she's
like oh god is that Oh
GSS [ __ ] Oh [ __ ] a baby clean a baby
queen okay okay say this where's your
[ __ ] face show your face [ __ ] show
your [ __ ] face Shou your [ __ ] face
you know [ __ ] he's [ __ ] [ __ ]
Jesus I can't scare ya [ __ ] okay okay
let's sit yeah hey it's activism at ran
scare scape once I power this up we'll
be ready to broadcast [ __ ] parrot is
this thing made well yes it could be
worse see what you can do with it I'm
gonna go see what else is left around
this old place 10 power okay then let's
say all I need there's just an great
expertise
now
hi wow we really did it fall to pieces
for so long not just now we've got to
pay off on what we start otherwise
thanks for watching